- Thank you to Surfshark VPN
for supporting this PBS video.
Picture a small town on the
coast of 19th century Wales.
A family gathers around the hearth,
a pan of butter toffee
bubbling on the embers.
The house is decorated with
branches of fragrant pine,
and the glow from small
candles perched on the limbs
of a Christmas tree lights the room.
Through a window, they see
torch light coming up the path
towards the cottage,
accompanied by chanting.
Suddenly three hard raps at the door.
(door knocking)
(mysterious music)
It flies open and an impossibly tall
and terrifying figure
looms over the family.
draped in dirty white linens,
its head is a horse's skull
with glass baubles in the eye sockets.
Ribbons tied about the skull are streaming
in the wind behind it like the hair
of some horrific sea monster.
Then all at once the
group begins a merry tune,
stomping and clapping in time
with the grim horse's head bobbing along.
The family responds with a
joyful verse of their own,
and before long, the whole
gaggle has made their way
into the cottage and are
clanking tankards together.
Sounds like we just stepped into a scene
from A Nightmare Before Christmas,
when in fact it is a
centuries-old tradition
from Wales called Mari Lwyd.
One, it seems, of many to blend a bit
of scary into their Merry Christmas.
(proud music)
I'm Dr. Emily Zarka, and this is Monstrum.
Mari Lwyd, though often used as a name
to describe the monster is actually
the name of the tradition itself.
This Christmastime creature is
composed of an animal skull,
usually equine or bovine
attached to the top
of a pole with a sackcloth
or sheet draped down
from the head to obscure
the bearer beneath.
The skull is often elaborately decorated.
Some accounts detail glass
ornaments as eyes along
with ribbons, bells,
and other accoutrements.
One thing is always present, however,
and that is the group that
travels with Mari Lwyd.
To help us gain a better
understanding of this tradition,
it is important to first
discuss an ongoing practice
in the British Isles called wassailing.
Wassailing is a Christmastime
tradition dating back
to the Middle Ages.
Although the specifics
of the practice vary
from region to region, it
generally involves a group
of people traveling house
to house, sharing drinks
and singing with the village folk.
The tradition usually involves some form
of performative bartering,
like taking a drink from the wassail bowl
in exchange for some type of gift.
Although wassailing is still
practiced in some pockets
of the British Isles,
the tradition has grown
and evolved over time into
what many people today
would call caroling.
So how does a skull fit into all of this?
We'll get into the varied
opinions on the origins
a bit later, but for now,
let's talk logistics.
The Mari Lwyd is one of the main members
of the Welsh wassailing entourage.
Along with our skeletal friend,
there is usually someone
who leads the group on their rounds
and is the most formally dressed.
Other characters like the famous violent,
rosy-cheeked puppets Punch and
Judy are oft included as well
This troop makes their
way through the town,
and upon arriving at a home
will begin singing a call
and response verse of sorts
with the tenants within.
There are many versions
of the song, both old
and contemporary, but
generally the song consists
of the wassailers asking for permission
to enter the home to feast and drink.
The people within then
respond in song alike
with excuses for why
they can't let them in.
This carries on until the
people inside can produce
no further excuses, and are required
to grant entry, mass merriment ensues.
Again, the specifics vary by
region and by time period,
(child screaming)
but generally once
inside the band partakes
in holiday treats and share ale
while their cranial creation would
playfully chase after the children
and adults eliciting
screams and laughter alike.
Some elaborate Mari Lwyd
creations might even feature
a snapping mandible made possible
through a lever or pole
string contraption.
Interestingly enough, this is actually one
of the British Isle's many
hooded animal traditions.
There are the Old Horse, Old Ball,
and Old Tup traditions
of Northern England,
the Hoodening of Kent, and
the Broad of the Cotswolds.
Although these others
often used a much less
menacing hobby horse of sorts,
and aren't always
associated with Christmas.
So where exactly did
this tradition come from,
and what does the name
Mari Lwyd actually mean?
There is some disagreement on both counts.
Iorwerth Peate, a 20th century Welsh poet
and scholar wrote that he believed
the Mari Lwyd to be a pagan tradition
that predates Christianity much like many
of the other traditions
practiced around the holidays.
However, there is no historical evidence
that really supports this assumption.
Nevertheless, he and others latched
onto the supposed ancient
origins of the custom.
Peate believed the practice
was rooted in fear.
The winter holidays mark a time
of darkness, cold and death.
A skeletal horse skull does
certainly evoke demise.
Although Peate originally thought
that Mary must be a
reference to the Virgin Mary,
he later backtracked and claimed
that the word is most likely a version
of the word "mare", as in female horse.
Other Welsh scholars of
the 20th century seem
to agree with him, for the most part,
Ellen Ettlinger, a British art collector
and folklorist believed Mari
Lwyd to have connections
to the Pagan holiday,
Samhain, evoking death.
Some folklorists suggest
that it may at one point have
symbolized fertility, and over time simply
became associated with good luck.
There are many equine
divinities in the Celtic Isles,
like Rhiannon in Wales, Epona
in Gaul, and Macha in Ireland.
But there is very little
evidence to support
these theories given
the lack of references
to these practices in any documents
from the late medieval era.
There is however plenty of
documentation from the 16th
and 17th centuries for hobby
horses throughout the region.
Costume folklore characters
meant to evoke real horses,
they were often used by jesters
and other merrymakers
during the Middle Ages.
We see references to them as early
as the 1300s in a poem by a Welsh author
where he poked some fun at the hobby horse
as having a miserable pair of lathe legs,
AKA, really skinny wood legs.
One of the earliest
known written references
we have to the Mari Lwyd
appears only in the 19th century
where it is condemned as immoral.
Rather than being part of
some ancient pagan tradition,
the Mari Lwyd is likely a
uniquely menacing Welsh adaptation
of the British Isles' many
hooded animal traditions.
The etymology of the Mari
Lwyd is thus unsurprisingly
similarly murky with many scholars divided
on the actual origins.
It has become consensus
that the term likely means gray mare,
particularly since the word "llwyd"
translates to gray in Welsh.
This would also make sense
as it parallels other
hobby horse traditions
throughout the region, namely
in Ireland and the Isle of Man
In the Celtic language Manx, it is known
as the "laare vane", which
translates to white mare.
But a connection to the
Virgin Mary still exists
in many modern iterations
of the Mari Lwyd,
with very clear references
to the mother of Jesus
in several of the traditional songs.
But hey, it is Yule time after all.
Despite this inclusion
of Christian elements
in the tradition, the
Mari Lwyd was not a part
of the public consciousness for most
of the early 20th century
because of disapproval
from local Christian clergy
and general movement away
from more ancient practices in
an increasingly modern world.
However, by the mid-century,
Mari Lwyd started creeping
its way back into the light.
A 1941 poem by Vernon Watkins called
"The Ballad of the Mari
Lwyd" was well-received
in Welsh literary circles, as
was Susan Cooper's 1977 novel
"Silver on the Tree", in
which Mari Lwyd appears
as an undead unicorn and
protector of a magic sword
in the mythical sunken lands
off the coast of Wales.
How that's not a movie
yet is a mystery to me.
Later, the Mari Lwyd
became better known outside
of Wales via the tabletop
role-playing game,
Dungeons and Dragons.
In D&D, the Mari Lwyd is an undead horse
that speaks only in rhyme
with a chattering jaw,
and seeks entry into people's
homes where it devours food
and drink before needing a place to sleep,
behavior clearly inspired
by the original folklore.
In 2000, the artist Clive
Hicks-Jenkins featured Mari Lwyd
in a series of drawings
that personified the monster
as the horrific bringer
of his father's death.
This series was accompanied
by poems by Catriona Urquhart,
titled "The Mayor's Tale".
Local Celebrations that Included
the Mari Lwyd became more
and more commonplace throughout Wales
as the 20th century wore
on, culminating in a turn
of the millennium jubilee in the town
of Aberystwyth wherein they
rang in the new century
with an elaborate
procession throughout town.
Their top-billed attraction
being a massive representation
of the creature dubbed "The
World's Largest Mari Lwyd".
Christmastime celebrations
that include the tall, dark,
and fearsome creation
continue throughout Wales
and parts of England to this day.
as regular Monstrum viewers may know,
Christmastime monsters
lurk in the holiday shadows
of many cultures and traditions.
There's Frau Perchta,
also known regionally
as the Italian La Befana,
the Russian Babushka,
or the Slavic Baba Yaga.
From Iceland, we have Gryla
and her offspring the prankster Yule Lads,
not to mention our favorite
murder-floof, the Yule cat.
And of course, most famous,
Krampus, the half-goat,
half-demon anti-Santa who
punishes naughty children.
And this begs the question,
why during a holiday
so associated with joy and festivity
do we have so many monsters,
so much darkness and fear?
To answer that we need
to look at celebrations
of the winter solstice.
The winter solstice has always been
viewed as an important time.
The harvest seasons have
now come to a close.
The cold chill begins to blow in
and weather becomes
increasingly less hospitable.
Traditionally without
much work to do for those
who would otherwise be plowing the fields,
they often pass the hours by drinking
and telling stories by the fire.
The Roman festival of
Saturnalia occurring on
or around the solstice was
a holiday of opposites.
Masters would serve their slaves,
the rich would garner gifts for the poor,
and enslaved and free men alike would take
to the streets in disguise to engage
in all manner of Roman debauchery.
Yule was a Nordic and Germanic tradition,
which involved feasting and celebration,
but was also rife with animal sacrifice
and the ceremonial smearing
of blood all over the temple,
and the worshipers in attendance.
Humans have always had a
complicated relationship
with the coming of winter.
The cold, dark depths of our
chilliest season bring about
a sense of wonder and also dread.
Whether we choose to approach it head on
via the spooky Christmas
characters of Europe
or to sugarcoat it with
candy canes and gum drops.
Winter is a time of
contemplative reflection
on the small death of
our world as it freezes.
and sometimes the merry and the scary
are a perfect marriage.
As is the case with the Mari Lwyd,
which despite its grim
visage is actually viewed
by all participants as jolly good fun.
Thank you to Surfshark VPN
for supporting this PBS video.
Surfshark VPN is a virtual
private network designed
to keep your online identity safe
by encrypting all the information sent
between your device and the internet.
Using a VPN when on public
wifi can help provide safety
while surfing the internet,
as well as working from home.
A lot of online services
use sophisticated targeting
and tracking services, but a VPN can
provide protection from that.
Surfshark's CleanWeb feature
is built to block ads,
trackers, malware, and phishing attempts.
And if you do a lot of
international traveling,
Surfshark allows clients to
change their virtual location.
There's over 3,200 servers in
more than a hundred countries
designed to help make sure you can access
your home country's
features while traveling.
To learn more, click the link
in the description below.
As long as I have you here,
I wanna give you a heads up
that the new season of our sister show,
Fate & Fabled is underway.
This season promises more
stories of action, romance,
and mystery that have been told
in our weird world's
folklore and mythology
throughout the ages.
If you haven't checked it out already,
join me in Dr. McTier for the new season
of Fate & Fabled here on Storied.
Our Skeletal friend!
Some elaborate Mari Lwyd.
Are you sure this is your name?
In the town of Aberystwythwyth.
I have to do that again.
'Cause it sounds like it's not a word!